well
submission is it's kind of i'm probably
going to end up talking about this for
10 solid minutes so
the way that submission works and you
have to just throw away the pink
definition of it because that is it's
not the same thing trust me like
submission in marriage was a thing
before there was like you know absurd
whips chains and floggers like that's
not what we're talking about it's kind
of weird that people take it in that
immediate direction
but
submission is not being a quarrelsome
woman and letting a man lead the only
man that's not going to be okay with a
submissive woman is going to be a man
that needs his woman to lead him and
that's not a man that most women find
attractive but the thing about it is is
uh
not every woman needs to do
psychological healing and submission
work so i live in the midwest the
standard out there is a two-parent
christian household i will say in my
county 76 white but it's some of the
most well-rounded women out there
they're kind and they understand when
there's a
trusted proven and justified authority
they'll submit to that authority and i
mean like mentorship in college or like
talking to their manager or respecting
their parents or respecting the elderly
and things like that so it's like women
that grow up in a lower socioeconomic
status with poor modeling they need
submission work because uh the reason
why i like kevin samuels and how he
would call out black women is because
i'm puerto rican and so we have like
similar problems where we're out here
absolutely prepared to curse out and
fight men and then complaining that
we're single meanwhile our kids suffer
because of it and like me as a minority
woman i'm like no way like i can figure
this out so i had to learn how to not be
argumentative like i was when i was
first with my my husband we were dating
like it took a long time for me to stop
being rude because that was my baseline
and i had already done some work on it
okay so this is like really sad that i i
did work to be less rude just to be like
eh you need to do more but that i don't
talk anything i did not talk any
differently than the women in my family
that came before me i thought it was
normal and i didn't know that when you
disrespect men they don't feel love but
once i figured that out i was like well
that's not nice yeah i'm like okay well
i wanted to feel like i love
yeah
and why why do you think it's so hard
for us as women to like submit to a man
oh because most most men are not worth
submitting to legitimately most men are
true yeah
yeah so like my husband is a
a trained fighter
he's trained with weapons he's got the
financial piece down he's got his
fitness down like of course i'm
naturally gonna fall in line because the
man can do anything and everything to
protect me like i don't even worry about
my life
i have no fear so
that's what women don't have is access
to the masculine men that are willing to
go that far to protect them and would do
anything for them and it's like like
people act like i'm chained in the
kitchen or something but if i'm sick
like he takes care of me where if i'm
feeling like you know blue he'll bring
chocolate so like of course i'm gonna
follow his leaves and the thing is like
the women will say things like oh you
can't trust a guy to like stay at home
because like you you miss out on like
work opportunity but i'm like so but
maybe he can't trust you to spend money
on you yeah well you're home like i'm
like he could go the same way
so it's like relationships are always
going to be a risk
so
so like why are we freaking out when we
have to take a risk they have to do it
too they can look at their [ __ ] i
actually so i wrote about this last
night uh let me see if i can pull it up
but
the the thing about young men and young
women what they want out of the dating
market or like whatever they end up
putting out that's vitriol it's because
they're like they're looking at the fear
what if this fails what if this happens
if you decide to pursue romance you're
going to encounter fear like it's not
it's not safe like my husband could wake
up tomorrow and be like well that was
fun but get out of my house you're like
i don't worry about that because i don't
i don't want to live in fear and that
can really like overtake your mind as a
woman so i ended up writing this i said
i get asked this question a lot about
marriage what if she leaves him what if
he leaves her if you want risk-free
romance stay in situation shifts because
no one comes out of human romance
entirely unscathed and this is the harsh
reality that's why people push back
people can't stomach
that people don't leave people they were
afraid of losing and this is for both
men and women alike so if you've ever
been left by someone to them you were
worth leaving
yeah
yeah that's that's really good
if you want each other in a marriage
like you then you're gonna stay if
you're afraid to be without them you're
gonna stay and that doesn't have to be
like a horrible awful fear you know it's
not it's not about like oh my god if i
leave it my life is over
it's like oh if i if i leave i'm like my
life's gonna be messed up and i'm not
gonna be happy so of course you wanna
stay